we want to get you a look at traffic  right now here at noon on this  labor day and you are taking a live look  at the 15 freeway  in prim those are the lanes heading  toward the screen those are southbound  and yeah there's been a lot of traffic  leaving las vegas going towards southern  california this morning  nhp said there was a 12-mile backup from  gene  down to prim that was about an hour ago  and they do expect traffic to get worse  as we get into the afternoon and the  evening and you can see it is still  really slow going in the southbound  lanes northbound lanes look ok  though so be prepared for that if you  are headed on the road later today